clap
clap like you're about to die
clap
happy tuesday everyone what a great show
we have tonight like a packet of smoked
meat sticks
we got two slim jims
jim norton and jimmy failure
yeah one looks like an escaped serial
killer who targets the homeless and the
other one looks like his next victim
degen looks like the one who'd find the
body while she was jogging and then
takes the watch while cat takes a kidney
she says it's good for the skin
now there's a good chance that i make
you sick to your stomach like say a 40
chance about the same odds you'd get if
you eat the clam plate at denny's that's
according to university of nebraska
experts who claim that four in 10 people
cite politics as a top life stressor
it's so bad that it causes insomnia
destroys relationships and for at least
five percent causes them to feel
suicidal but so does watching emily in
paris but i'm not quitting that either
it really is delightful in the second
season getting picked up for a third
they blame politics for causing fatigue
anger and compulsive behaviors and
that's just from the staff of fox and
friends
quarter claim they're thinking of moving
because of the politics in their state
especially california which explains why
u-hauls are harder to find than an
actress with her real nose
can you blame them
politics suck and our politicians are
suckier look at them their faces should
be on the back of household cleaning
products to induce vomiting if swallowed
and pelosi's investment success has
raised some eyebrows including hers to
the top of her forehead
we're a country run by evil rejects from
the muppets except they've got their
hands up your butt
and it doesn't feel as good as it used
to
so much like
smoking weed
politics started as a thing to prevent
people from killing each other you
created a process that enables debate to
eliminate the need for duels which is
good try buying a decent sword on amazon
i've tried but over time politics has
become less of a mayhem reducer and more
the opposite a conflict stirrer why is
it getting worse well experts blame
social media websites podcasts and the
non-stop tv news cycle but notice how
they leave out legacy media it's on us
and not them but one thing's true cable
news has a content problem which is a
time problem how do you fill 24 hours
with 20 minutes of news it's like trying
to feed brian stelter only one box of
twinkies
so you just repeat it over and over and
over again back when i was a kid you got
your nudes at 6 pm then you finished
your swanson's tv dinner adjusted your
polio braces and all was right with the
world
too soon i don't know now
we can take one story and like the skin
on jerry nadler's trunk stretch it for
three days
the media declares a crisis then covers
their coverage of it then covers
reaction to their coverage no wonder
people feel bad but just imagine how
much happier you'd be if you tuned it
all out
[Music]
oh my god lori did you see the news last
night it's infuriating i couldn't sleep
oh no i was stargazing the universe is
wonderful
what an
idiot have you read this crazy stuff is
happening oh no i've just been admiring
this beautiful drawing my niece made me
have you listened to the podcast angry
men discuss politics oh no i've been
listening to sounds of the ocean
oh my god
well you better educate yourself or
you're never gonna
survive
[Music]
excellent acting
but here's the kicker people actually
now feel worse under biden than in trump
when trump was president according to
gallup in just one year we saw a swing
from a nine point democratic advantage
to a five-point gop edge that's a shift
of 14 points according to our point
shifting department
shout out to seth good job
that's pretty big when you consider the
media is still 95 liberal and also that
biden was supposed to be a jar of relief
factor after trump's four-year rug burn
biden was supposed to bring people
together except we didn't know it would
be in a line waiting for covent tests so
people feel worse under joe perhaps
because he's more divisive than a man
within a magician with a circular saw
now your instinct is to blame these guys
understandable they're a-holes but
they're being led by bigger a-holes our
politicians now chase recognition from
the most extreme media types to get the
dopamine rush the dems throw that beast
more red meat in 24 hours than a
zookeeper on ritalin it's why biden
instead of fighting crime or inflation
calls half of america bigots his staff
is merely checking what crap tends to
trend on woke twitter and then spoon
feeds it to the old coot like his wife
does his strained beets
what say you joe
come on look look look some
some people think i'm angry don't
believe everything you hear i'm never
angry i'm uncle joe all right
people like me and
i don't believe
people are as unhappy as they say it
depends on
who you ask depends on who
count the votes
count the votes
count the votes
cut the votes
okay well it comes and goes
it does come and go but also look at the
modern progressive activists we've seen
anti-fog mug shots pale faces purple
hair rotted teeth lazy eyes what jim
norton calls a solid nine
the study finds the people most
vulnerable to political stress are
younger lean democrat and are more
actively engaged in political causes
they're more likely to dye their hair
shocking colors too that's nature's way
of warning you about poisonous frogs or
a poisonous liberal arts major but it
makes sense if you choose an angry
bitter framing of the world you too will
be angry and bitter if you view
everything through a racial prism you
might end up with your own show on msnbc
but you won't find a moment of happiness
in your life
everything's racist it's joyless
you'll be constantly pissed off by your
faulty framing and no one wants to be
around that
finally the researchers see their data
as a bad sign for democracy that if
people view politics as harmful they
won't get involved
and why is that bad exactly they just
said the more involved you are the worse
it is maybe swallowing all that junk
food is bad for you if you're injecting
politics into everything from sports to
house paint you're replacing knowledge
with rhetoric and losing friends family
and your mind in the process so if your
head hurts because you keep hitting it
with a hammer then put down the hammer
or if you're don lemon keep at it it can
only help
welcome tonight's guests
he's not allowed within 50 feet of
schoolyards junkyards or barnyards
comedian and co-host of the jim norton
and sam roberts show on siriusxm jim
norton
yes
she's the crabbiest virginian this side
of the chesapeake bay fox business
anchor daegan mcdowell
he's hailed by all comedy lovers to give
them a ride home after the show
because he's a cab driver [ __ ] across
america hosts jimmy failure love
whatever
and she asked her accountant if hair
extensions are a tax write-off fox news
contributor cat tim
jimmy it is great to see you i thought
you hated me no i love you uh we hadn't
talked in so long sometimes i'd lay
awake at night and stare at a grainy
picture of you i took i would do the
same thing and i'm probably doing the
same thing you were doing in my picture
i don't know about that
politics make you sick and if so why
by the way i could never tell your
politics when we were doing red eye i
never knew where you stood on anything
it was amazing greg i believe if five
people can sit in a circle with their
legs crossed we can agree on anything
and uh
politics is really how i get myself
primed to make love oh really oh yeah i
like to say who i voted for in the
primaries while she puts clothes pins on
my nipples yeah not enough political
talk
that is your foreplay um well you know
degen uh some people see politics as a
sport right it's like uh to them fox
news is their espn
no no sports or sports um i politics
doesn't make me sick though people do
yes i really hate people yes people
particularly people who are so sure
about their own beliefs that they don't
think that they have opinions about
anything that they have complete
certitude in in what they think and what
they believe is right and just and then
if you disagree with them they treat you
well like you're inhuman like a racist
sleaze stack yes with a bad cough
like they want to when people and
they'll argue with you using delicious
factoids from bette midler's twitter
feed you know the people who are going
to watch rex chapman's show on
cnn plus that is so far removed from
reality uh i i don't even know who that
is but he's on cnn plus which means that
no one will know who he is
dead
on twitter who just like narrowed down
way more purposes
what's that on twitter so far that's all
of them yes
to your point it's like people that are
that strident in politics their filter
is too narrow to have an actual broad
conversation about anything because
everything goes back to race everything
goes back to oppression everything goes
back to owning the libs whatever right
and they never have any well
they get their information from like
bette midler and cher
and nicole wallace that that is their
circle that is the circle and cycle of
idiocy it's a three-headed yes it's a
three-headed beast yes with only sharing
one brain you know uh uh jimmy men's
warehouse called they released a
statement they don't like the way you
look get out of town
this is normally god you're like a
homeless don johnson well i always say
this is like my jacksonville vice look
like i'm not good looking enough for
miami vice but also it's like an
unspoken thing when you have another
comic on the panel wearing white as a
way of telling them there's someone who
can get cocaine in your proximity that's
like a it's like a little safety sign
for hand gestures but normally i would
attack you but i actually have a
question tonight i've considered a fair
question if they ever reboot the tv show
webster is emmanuel lewis going to want
his wardrobe back
is he still alive i don't even know i
hope he's alive and writes an angry
letter to god he'd be well within his
rights um you know he's like 60 so who
cares anybody who doesn't think like
politics damages your mental health to a
point you made earlier has never been on
twitter which really is as you know it's
just a fight club for people who don't
want to get hit you know you could post
a picture of your dog on twitter and
within two comments someone's like yeah
but trump and you're like yeah my dog
didn't vote for trump my dog has no idea
but i think part of the reason why we've
gotten to this place of like hostility
as i think your analogy about espn is
valid i think people are rooting for
their party so hard that they're just
blindly taking sides now regardless of
whether or not it's good or it's sane or
it's factual they just want their side
to be right and what happened to the
left the reason they're hemorrhaging
support is they're not a cool party
anymore like the left used to be a free
speech sex drugs and rock and roll
parties they were cool they won every
culture war right now they're on the
wrong side of that issue and like the
rage against the machine people are now
in the machine like they're like screw
you you don't support big pharma where
the government yeah it's like psychotic
yeah so somehow they made the right
which is criminally uncool kind of cool
yes it's the dean wermer effect they
used to be animal house and we used to
be dean warmer now we're animal house
and they're dean warmer there's only two
characters you can play in life it's
animal house and dean wermer
cats politics sucks but can't is there
something that we can replace it with
like if you take politics away won't we
just go back to beating each other to
death
i feel like if two adults consent to a
duel they should be able to duel oh
really
i like that you a little libertarian
would be for that well why not yeah yeah
that's actually a good point
i have i'm full of them greg
yeah
i think those are needles no
[Laughter]
i've no i've never done anything
intravenously okay i i toe the line
um yeah i know i i think that most
people are independents though yeah yeah
and but you would not know that by
looking at something like twitter but
then you'll see people in like your real
life do get radicalized for partisan
reasons i've lost friends that way the
fact that i have people who hate me
because of my politics is crazy like me
like i'm an annoying attention-seeking
nightmare of a person but sure like my
politics is going to be the problem that
you have with me only if you're crazy
yes yes i don't even get to your
politics no i mean i stop at just
meeting you hi
i'm like get the hell away from this
lady but i'm still here how many years
later i don't know i have a uh
you got pictures
and not of me that's the weird thing no
she's got them of me
and i'm standing above you that's the
weird thing i'm out of the shots
well part of me hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else